- Hello teachers, I'm Meaghan.
Welcome to Khan for Educators,
initial course for
teachers on Khan Academy.
You are about to begin an
exciting learning journey.
But first, let's look together
at the path that lies ahead.
To get started click the
start training button
to begin learning.
This course has one unit
composed of seven lessons
in which we explore everything
from getting started on Khan Academy
to classroom implementation
and diving deeper into Khan
Academy's teacher reports.
The course begins with the lesson
Getting to know Khan Academy.
Which shares a little about our commitment
to high quality education,
and the learning experience
we hope to provide.
Then we have the lesson
Setting up you teacher account,
which covers the main teacher functions,
setting up classes, an overview
of Khan Academy content,
and a walkthrough of
the student experience.
The third lesson, Introduction
to mastery learning
provides a broad overview
of mastery learning
and address frequently asked questions
relating to mastery learning.
The fourth lesson, Using
course mastery on Khan Academy
dives deeper into Khan Academy's
mastery learning system.
This lesson includes a cursory look
at Khan Academy's progress reports
and showcases teacher insights
on using progress data with students.
Lesson five, Using assignments
to support mastery learning
details how to create and
manage student assignments
and how to leverage Khan
Academy's assignment report
to support mastery learning with students.
Lesson six focuses on implementing
Khan Academy with students.
In this lesson we go
further into the logistics
of using Khan Academy with students
including our recommended
implementation model,
classroom best practices,
and student motivation.
In lesson seven, teaching
remotely with Khan Academy,
we explore implementation recommendations
and tips for teaching students
beyond the walls of your classroom.
These resources are
designed to support teachers
and students in remote
learning experiences
using Khan Academy and
other educational tools.
The course concludes
with a next step section
that explores the different opportunities
for further education so
you can continue to learn
and innovate in your classes.
Khan for Educators was designed
so teachers, coaches, and administrators
could experience Khan Academy as students.
So in order to complete the course
you'll need to engage with exercises,
master skills, and perform
well on the final assessment.
But don't worry, there's
a reward for those
who complete this journey.
Your professional
learning is in your hands,
start Khan for Educators
initial course right now
and find out how Khan Academy can expand
the possibilities in your classroom.
Do you have any questions
about the course?
Access the help center
for additional support.
See you soon.